I'm Robin Lively and I'm so excited to
share with you all the exclusive
premiere of the season to be trailer of
Amazon's Gordimer Gibbons life on normal
Street right here on ET online check
this up is this a new worm really cool
I've lived my whole life on on the
street there's a lake at one end and a
forest or shady trees at the other but
what lies in between is anything but
normal in my magnetic I've been sticky
all day this is serious you could become
a black hole that the end of you on the
strip there's a horse black isn't it I
made this potion in chemistry lab I
that's just the tip of the iceberg
they're gonna have to create a new
category for fun these we're taking it
to a whole new weapon
what's going on with you and your mom I
have something to tell you guys my mom
sold our house and we have to move
quarter I know are you kidding
everything's gonna change we have three
months let's make them count what do you
think another hundred true friends want
you to be happy no matter what quarter
you're the best friend in the world I
think it's time for a whole new Gordimer
I'm adding this to the list of our bad
ideas there's a list what else is on it
just this